well hello there you're watching the
press preview first look at what's on
the front pages as they arrive here in
sky studios
in the next half an hour we'll be seeing
what's making the headlines with the
daily express columnist carol malone and
the editor at the courier david clegg a
very good evening to both of you hello
but first let's see what's on some of
those front pages shall we
and the queen's conversation with health
leaders about the vaccine rollout
dominates the headlines tonight
including this one the mirror the
express is calling it
queen's shock message one
is not immune says the says the headline
for the metro is it also splashes on the
queen's vaccine endorsement
and it's the same story on the front of
the telegraph queen
says refusing vaccine is selfish
while the male also leads with her
majesty's words
and the front of the sun right as reign
the headline for them
well the eye newspaper has a budget
preview it says nhs workers will
not get a pay rise more predictions for
next week's budget
in the times with the headline sunac's
tax rate on
pensioners reporting the chancellor's
post-covered economic plan
mr potato head losers meet him two veg
is the daily styles top story as the
children's
toy goes gender neutral warnings about
the climate crisis lead the guardian it
says more storms and
colder weather could be coming to the uk
and alex salmon's inquiry appearance
tomorrow has been dubbed the hollyridge
showdown
by the curry courier
well let's bring in carol and david
shall we and start then with her
majesty's
interesting royal audience we don't
often hear from her majesty in this kind
of way do we carol what did you make of
it all
no i think it's come at exactly the
right time this intervention what she's
basically saying and it's made
most of the front pages tomorrow she's
saying it's important that people
get this vaccine they've got to think of
others before themselves
she was it was a video chat with um with
vaccine rollout leaders and she's very
passionate about the vaccine she's had
it herself
um and she's you know she's trying to
tell people it doesn't hurt that you
should get it and the queen
and people might not know but she's
credited with boosting
boosting the vaccine rollout for polio
in the 50s lots of people were scared of
getting that too
and she revealed publicly and remember
the queen
the monarch didn't talk about her kids
back then but she was ill publicly
that her children had had the vaccine
and that helped with the rollout and
maybe
that's what she's doing this for now
patrick valencia patrick barnes has
estimated that one in five people
won't get the vaccine no because there
are lots of kind of
people are citing lots of crazy reasons
why they won't have it it's um
women some women are fearful that they
won't get pregnant again
um various ethnic minorities um are
frightened of what's in it they've been
told stop what's in it
um the the it hasn't lots of people
saying it hasn't been tested properly
so it's kind of there is resistance to
this and we can't have a situation where
you know you have four fifths of the
country vaccinated the other half not
because they pose a danger
to each other and to everyone else so
it's important that this message gets
across
yeah and as you said there has been no
scientific evidence to back up any of
those concerns that you listed there
carol i mean it's interesting isn't it
david we don't
really tend to hear her majesty's
opinions on anything but in this
instance it is
well not just helpful but i suppose
deemed uh acceptable in terms of the
royal protocol
yes i mean it's not a political point
she's making what she's saying is
absolutely medical fact there's no
discussion or debate about that amongst
people who know what they're talking
about
i think the point that carol makes there
about the polio vaccine and this long
history
was actually quite interesting i think
because what it brought home to us is
that
vaccine skepticism is not new it's a
it's a long-standing thing
that's the case from the 50s there was
also obviously the
mmr vaccine and the the various scares
about that
in the late 1990s and we now have this
situation at the minute which the
vaccine
minister has said there's a tsunami of
misinformation out there about that
i think the problem is more acute now
because of the information
ecosystem we have because of social
media if you go on social media
anywhere it's a awash with false claims
about what the vaccine can do
we've also seen politicians who frankly
should know better in europe
uh making claims about the efficiency of
the vaccine
which are false and have caused serious
problems there we're seeing more
problems i think with skepticism
about the vaccine in countries like
france and germany because of some of
the issues that their politicians have
got into
so i do think this is a very welcome
move from the queen
i i guess the question is uh what
kind of impact does it have these days
on people who have
fallen down these social media rabbit
holes and
are worried about the prospects of the
vaccine but really we need every voice
with
any authority and credibility to be
speaking out and doing this because
what we have seen in the uk is after
you know what most people would say has
probably been a pretty poor response to
the covert pandemic in general
we certainly seem to have been pretty
good on getting the vaccine rule out
right i think the uk government
uh deserve credit for that and so now
that they know that they we have this
vaccine available to us
that the infrastructure has been put in
place well i think it's it's vital
that everyone who is eligible gets it as
quickly as possible of course the queen
does have a global platform doesn't she
and we know that emmanuel macron has
today said that he would
take the oxford vaccine if he was
offered it but you wonder if anyone in
france hearing from her majesty might
change their mind and we should say also
carol um it's nice to see her majesty
smiling and looking relaxed given this
will be her husband's 10th night in
hospital the duke of edinburgh
and he's been you know on everyone's
minds these last few days
and we we all wish him incredibly well
it's it would
be you know i was i've been thinking
about this a lot this week you know it
would feel very wrong if something
happened to him now
you don't want to see eyes with them
lose their their each other's rock and
we don't want to see that happen
but can i just go back you know macro
i'm now talking about endorsing
aspersilica he is the person who put the
frighteners on everybody
when there was a big round over the
procurement
a month or so ago um they all wanted
astrazeneca then when they realized they
couldn't get it when germany and france
couldn't commandeer our supplies
they started rubbish again saying it
didn't work now because the vaccine
rollout is so bad in france
less than one in 10 people have been
vaccinated they now have to try
to try and repatriate the asterisk and
say that it works
because the propaganda that both the
german government have put out
and the french government have put
people off and this is this is why it's
so important the queen is saying this
now because
propaganda works in countries like
france and germany
the front page of build the build
newspaper today in germany the biggest
selling newspaper
said we envy you brits because they're
not getting vaccinated and we are and
it's mostly the fault of their leaders
who
a didn't order the vaccines early enough
and
and b who poured astrazeneca and you
know the proof of the pudding is here
where you know their rates are
plummeting in this country we're going
to be out by june
they're going into their their third
wave and possibly another lockdown in
both of those countries yeah absolutely
um david should we take a look now at
the eye
newspaper and turn our attention to next
week's budget and
of course everybody's been hailing and
clapping haven't they for nhs workers
over the last year
and yet no nhs pay rise in the budget
as it stands at the moment yes the the
eye newspaper is reporting on its front
page tomorrow that there will be no pay
rise
for nhs workers in rishi sunak's budget
next week i think that if that is the
case it will be
a very controversial decision uh we i
knew that
we knew that the unions unison in
particular have been calling for a
significant pay rise they would like a
flat payment of 2 000 points for
all nhs workers i think and even in
scotland this week there was an
announcement from the
scottish government the day we had an
interim pay rise of one percent
which they're back dating to the start
of december with the intent of seeing
what happens in the budget next week and
what uh what's known as barnet
consequentials which is the money that
land flew through to the scottish
government to see what pay rise
they can they could provide in in
scotland but even that announcement of a
one percent prairie rise was was
was met with actually a bit of anger
from from the tree from the trade unions
from unison here they're saying that
that's not enough
so if we actually get to next week and
uh we're told
there's no pay rise at all i think i
think there'll be a lot of anger
especially because we have said over the
last year
uh nhs heroes the the
work that they've had to do uh
unimaginable for those of us who haven't
had to be on the front line of the
coveted pandemic
so if we do get to a new pay rise
situation i think that could be a very
difficult political
situation for the chancellor and the
conservative government yeah very
emotive one that
indeed um carol let's take a look before
we go to the advert break
at the daily mirror this story again in
lots of the papers quite an
extraordinary story really lady gaga
offering
a reward for anyone to come forward
after her dog walker was shot
four times in the chest this is this is
an incredible story you know it's we all
love our dogs but you know she's she's
offered this
500 dollar no questions
asked a reward for the people who stole
her dogs to bring them back
she doesn't seem to be too worried about
the fact that the dog walker a guy
called
ryan fish has been shot four times in
the chest he's gonna live but it's
hardly the point
you know and what this does not only is
does it seem a little bit heartless
on her part with the total disregard for
the lord she's actually been slammed by
the fbi for this but also this creates a
market
for for people who to steal celebrity
dogs
because this has had exactly the kind of
effect that those people who stole her
dogs it was two guys in
dark clothing it's this has had exactly
the kind of effect they wanted
those dogs those french bulldogs that
were stolen can bring up to 10 grand on
on the urban market however she's
offering them 500 grand
for two dogs so this is going to happen
to other celebrities and god forbid that
it looks like there may be of the
shootings because of it this will make
them desperate
now a whole new angle to sort of
american gun crime problem and
inadvertently
setting a bouncy unbelievable um we have
to leave it there but we will be back
after the break with lots more including
the hollywood showdown alex salmon's
appearance tomorrow making the headlines
like this
from david's courier see you in a moment
welcome back we're taking a look at
tomorrow's papers in the press preview
with the daily express columnist carol
malone and the editor
at the courier david clegg welcome back
to both of you
um of course this huge story that's been
in a bit of political theater
all week and promises to continue for
the next couple uh carol this on the
front of the telegraph
tomorrow nicola sturgeon struggling to
contain the
snp rebellion where does this all lead
you know this story's been kind of
rumbling on for weeks but it's actually
exploded
in the last three or four days i i think
miss sturgeon was thinking it might go
away but
absolutely not i mean andrew o'neill did
an excursion piece in
the mail today talking about he called
scotland a banana republic
without the bananas and liam fox called
it what's it called as he said it was
being like a tin pot dictatorship i mean
he's right
um you know there are there is so much
happening there vital documents being
censored or banned the media has been
cowed
there there's important information is
being suppressed bloggers are being
threatened with jail and it seems like
all of the institutions
in scotland are colluding to protect
miss sturgeon
um you know she is accusing sound of
making wild
accusations um and yet salmon wants to
go into parliament and he is going in
tomorrow
and he wanted to go in this week but he
was told that 474 words of his statement
were going to be redacted
he says the words that have been
redacted from that statement are the
things
that would prove that nicola sturgeon
misled parliament
so it seems like everything is
conspiring in those institutions
to protect her and what's happened today
it's you know
nationalists have always been like
totally behind surgeon and the snp but
but support as you said is falling apart
in parliament as
nsps are saying to her that if it's
found there was a witch hunt
against someone she will have to resign
and there was a murray pill today saying
her
popularity is plummeted by 16 percent
well
i want to bring in david clegg of course
your paper carrying this and you've been
covering this story right from
day dot um where do you think this is
all going to lead and what are the
implications for the election in may
and dare i say for another independence
referendum and they're far-reaching
implications so i think i'll just start
by saying as a newspaper editor and
someone who's
been covering this story for two and a
half years who in fact broke the fact
broke the story that alex hammond was
under investigation for sexual
harassment
i don't recognize her description of
scotland or its institutions or its
media or indeed its parliament
nice clearly this is an extremely
serious situation
and there is no doubt that nicholas
sturgeon and the scottish government
have questions to answer but i think we
should remember what those questions
are and what the issue we are examining
here alex salmond
for a start has been cleared by a jury
of uh sexual
assault allegations so he is not on
trial here what this committee
investigation that he's appearing for
he's appearing in front of tomorrow is
for is to get to the bottom of why the
scottish government
civil service botched so badly and in a
humiliating way
their initial investigation into the
sexual harassment complaints
against him and how they field him
and the two women who made complaints
against him
now that is the nub of this issue but it
is that because you could not really
tell from much of the coverage that's
been going on about this
we're actually quite we're in a very
febrile we're in a very febrile
atmosphere but we're also at quite a
dangerous moment i think because
i'm gonna have to keep the crime to
cover up
for nicolas sturgeon is nonsense tonight
alex salmond is a wounded animal
he is angry and he is out for revenge
okay we're running out of time
we'll talk more about it next hour of
course we'll have more on that story
david claire carol malone thank you both
very much we'll have more on that story
at the top of the next hour as well
stay with us